das ist mein spitzname stoß sichere
panzerung hybrid hat ständig auf hey
leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen bei
einem video leute aber heute muss ich
erst mal wichtig hinsetzen wollte ich
hoffe natürlich wird es gut ich habe
mich immer wieder ein bisschen
positioniert wie man im hintergrund
schon sofort schön sehen kann
ich habe ihr versprochen desto prim
feuerlöscher konnte der hintergrund ja
falls jetzt wieder vergessen was ich
gesehen habe wo wir den gemacht haben
einfach nach diesem video schauen
heute geht es auch nur wieder um was
ganz anderes und zwar jetzt schon ich
brauche meinen laptop dafür erst wollte
ich kurz sagen dankeschön dass das
letzte video ich habe wirklich noch nie
so ein video gemacht haben ja viele
youtuber schon mal gemacht ich noch
nicht also ein erstes video ist echt
richtig gut angekommen 100% zufällig
bestellen ist über die trends gekommen
weil ich vorher auch noch nie
naja war wohl eine einmalige sache auf
jeden fall habt ihr gesagt er alex wir
wollen noch so frisch video sag mal ganz
kleine bewertung und in den kommentaren
auch ganz oft deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht wir machen heute partout
allerdings mit einer etwas anderen
challenge und zwar bei dem event video
ging es ja aus wie sie um luxus
klamotten heute geht es ausschließlich
um handy marken aurich bestellen das
ganze 100 prozent zufällig ich habe
wieder einen netten zufallsgenerator
hinter der kamera der auch ganz viele
handy war ausgesucht hat und ich würde
sagen wir lieber gar nicht lange bei
10.000 leicht gibt es noch ein paar
liegt an euch und letzte absolute
vielleicht zeige ich euch das hier mal
kurz wir haben ja gesagt du hast die
produkte vom letzten mal ja gar nicht
wirklich bestellt die man hier sehen
kann hier zum beispiel diese rolex
versand kommt bis zum 17
das ding ist halt leider ist nicht bei
allen produkten so zum beispiel hier
diese ps4 controller dockingstation oder
so kommt es bis zum 5 4
also wie genau ich das video machen
werde und wann das weiß ich noch nicht
wo ich halt die produkte auspacken
wir werden sehen das mache ich dann
spontan aber das sagen
aber das hat man als info dazu dass ihr
euch nicht wundert wurde das video
bleibt wo ich das so jetzt fällt mit dem
ersten produkt und das erste produkt ist
ein bzw
welche marke was nur bei ok kurve
wahrscheinlich kennt ihr geschäft
erfolgreicher bei gar nicht was mich
erwartet man hier gibt's sogar
schnelleren versand artikel mit
schnelleren versand
dann kann ich auch hiervon welche nehmen
wir jetzt erst mal von hier oben welche
ok welches produkt 86 story 1234
und jetzt haben 56 ja super magnetik
chart ra micro usb etwas hatten das mit
arbeit zu tun
die samsung ich kann sogar eine farbe
während gold beste und eine größe dafür
einfach magnetik charger micro usb
platten ab lag vor samsung huawei und
für einfach noch so das haben wir jetzt
schon mal drin
ok als nächstes bitte absolut und ihr
könnt auf jeden fall marie auf instagram
folgen ist kurz war eingebildet dann
freut sie sich sehr
falls sie die gar nicht kennt ja gar
nicht ihr gesicht weil die ist ja in
diesen bestellung des videos immer nur
hinter der kamera
was bist du
was als nächstes kommt nokia
die machen jetzt glaube ich wieder neue
handys ja gut okay einmal wird er die
zahl 11 noch eine dockingstation okay
wir würfeln bitte nochmal weil ich kann
jetzt nicht zwei ladegeräte kaufen so
123456 kostenlos was ist das überhaupt
premium panzerglas für iphone 4 leute
das ist echt geil also ich habe ein
iphone 7 plus und krieg hier einfach nun
premium panzer klasse was wollte ich
sowieso schon immer haben das ist ja für
welches iphone 3 das sieht man denke ich
mir nochmal kommt drauf an wie du dich
jetzt im laufe des videos verhält und
aber den versand kannst du dir zwei
jahren gibst du mir weiter ich guck mal
kurz vor der versand ist ja zwei euro
wer weiß das also soll ich jetzt
bestimmt hast du deinen ipod touch oder
ipod touch im liebevoll wird sich heute
irgendwie welchen iphone 7
blackberry war dieses handy gibt es das
überhaupt noch wer von euch kennt
blackberry okay ich hatte kein
blackberry ok wächst produkt die nummer
4 1 2 3 4 und wir haben hier was sollte
es auch anders sein ein auf ladekabel
ich war jetzt aber dieses kostet du ein
euro das ehepaar teurer ich wir haben
jetzt schon auf ladekabel samsung jetzt
müssen aber was anderes wir kriegen
samsung ist ein unterschied
na ja es geht also hier kommt wieder auf
neue kabel
ok dann gebe ich jetzt erstmal hier
zusammen so ja jetzt gut drei bis 13
sorry schon gut 1 2 3 4 5 812 und die 13
ja eine samsung nur für 13 euro
meist letztes machen wir doch handys
gefunden oder guck mal was ist jetzt
wenn ich hier einfach mal handy eingeben
hier kommen jetzt auch unter anderem
handys also iphone geben sein iphone
okay okay und jetzt meine nummer eins
zwei drei vier fünf
jetzt haben wir hier jetzt haben wir ein
handy hülle in rot aber das alte guck
mal guckt euch mal die handy geladen und
dies die soll gratis sein herr verstehen
das ding ist wahrscheinlich sicht nicht
natürlich für mainz welche farbe ja okay
für zwei euro kann man das mitnehmen so
auf jeden fall ich gebe jetzt einfach
mal iphone vor nein ich mache ja keinen
sei von handy geht jetzt mal so weil ich
will jetzt auch mein handy haben
ok es würfel nochmal bitte 22 12 jetzt
haben wir mal sieht aus wie ein iphone
aber ist ein ex coach das ist es jetzt
wohl meine fans werden ich nehme immer
einfach alles in gold das kaufe ich ja
das ding ist zusammen und lassen prima
finden
das ist so kacke dass die sachen hat
wirklich also in zwei monaten an kommen
zum teil soll nächste marke lg
[Musik]
da ist ja wer ganz up to date 10 12 48
wir haben hier eine stoß sichere
panzerung hybrid hart stände
es ist mein spitzname stoß sichere
panzerung hybrid hat ständer so heiß ich
auf yahoo
ok ich nehme es den leader so leute
haben jetzt die chance sich ihre panzer
schutzhülle in den warenkorb geschmissen
und wir gucken jetzt aber es war doch
als nächstes da sony sony wenn die da
bin ich jetzt mal gespannt also da muss
es jetzt wirklich handys
das ist sogar die orcas sind das bitte
für handy marken blöd ich habe gedacht
ich hätte im letzten video auch schon
ein handy gefunden
hey da bin ich wirklich gespannt ob das
gut ist ja weiter ich würde sagen eine
sache noch oder oder zwei sache noch ok
htc bhtc weil mein allererstes handy und
warte ich ein htc wildfire s wenn ich
mir jetzt gedanken darüber machen was
das für ein schrotthaufen
aber ich habe es geliebt damals das war
mein erstes handy man das werde ich nie
vergessen
124 wieder eine kostenlose panzer hülle
die haben wir aber schon machen wir
nochmal würfel noch mal 1978 und wir
haben hier lass mich raten ein richtig
google google handy google hat hier sein
neues google dinge ausgebaut
mal gucken was hier kommt ja hier kommen
denn dies ok einmal die neurotische nein
nein
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 wir haben hier eine
box für eine virtual reality bührle gut
so was wirklich schon immer haben die
leute ich gebe es jetzt auch hier wir
haben auf jeden fall ein paar handys
abstellen können ich würd sagen wir
schauen uns einfach mal kurz den
warenkorb an und gehen durch also wenn
wir einfach die virtuelle realität
brille box dann haben wir das ball via
handy sehr bekannte marke
hey ich hab doch einst ausgewählt über
zwei klar von 7.000 von 3.700 1 euro auf
32 euro runtergesetzt denn menowin
nickname bestellt den stoß jährige
panzerung hybrid hart stelle das sco die
handy echt ok nich stand reicht
vielleicht einmal hier diese hülle dann
die smartcovers ist damit zu tun hat die
panzer hölle kostenlos nochmal die
panzer über kostenlos und das
aufnahmegerät und wir sind jetzt uns
dann bei 150 euro 30 für zwei handys
zählen aufladegeräte 28 panzer erhöhen
ist das ja okay so
und vor allem die artikel kosten
zusammen 125 euro und das hat seinen 50
ja weiter damit jetzt nicht manch
wiederum öl diebe stellt es doch ähnlich
ich bin offen und ehrlich ich habe jetzt
nicht alles bestellt davon aber die
hände ich zum beispiel habe ich
bestellten lade gebe brauche ich nicht
habe ich alles schon diese höhen brauche
ich auch nicht aber es sind ja lustige
sollen sich ich hoffe dass wieder
durchgefallen das den daumen nach oben
dafür noch einen part und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder am morgen gibt's neues
video wie immer ich hoffe ihr freut euch
und yahoo ich wünsche euch ein schönes
wochen eine partner